when I read the Freedom of Information
Act a judge ordered the release of
emails a fauci and these virologists on
January 31st so about 10 30 at night
fauci begins exchanging emails he
exchanges them until three in the
morning you can tell by the tenor that
he's he's worried and he's concerned not
only about the origins but the origins
could Boomerang and come back and that
he could be exposed as the one who
approved the funding
joining me today is a senator from
Kentucky and author of the new book
deception The Great covid Cover-Up
Senator Rand Paul welcome back to the
Reuben report thanks for having me Dave
good to be with you
it's good to be with you before we dive
into the book and covid and I have a
feeling you don't really like this
Anthony fauci fella there is chaos in
the house of course you're in the Senate
but uh what do you make of this lunacy
at the moment
well you know I'm sympathetic to the
argument that we should do individual
spending bills that uh we should try to
use the power of the purse to bring down
spending just the last three months
we've accumulated over a trillion
dollars in new debt we've never added a
trillion dollars in three months before
so it is the spending is out of control
uh there is some blame to go around I
mean there's no budget the Republicans
pass no budget in the house and the
Democrats pass no budget in the Senate
neither party seems to be too concerned
with what's going on so no budget and
then the fiscal year ends on September
30th didn't pass any appropriation bills
zero the house passed one and now we're
laboring over trying to stick three or
four together but it's uttering
confidence and it's been going on for 40
years you know it makes me tempted to
want to vote for none of the above
I was gonna say does it like
particularly a guy like you who actually
cares about math and carrying the one
and making sure our bills are paid it's
sort of gotta like particularly stick
into your crawl but I guess you've
become accustomed to this kind of thing
but it's kind of a false debate too that
we're having because we're voting and
examining spending bills that comprise
16 of the budget so two-thirds of the
budget's entitlements and they said oh
no we're afraid we don't want to reform
the entitlements there's no money to
save two-thirds of the budget we're not
going to look at and then the remaining
third half of its military and they said
oh we want to give the military an
increase of three percent so
entitlements are going up at five
percent military is going up to three
percent and then they left 16 of the
budget this is about 700 billion dollars
and they said oh we're going to try to
hold the line on on this and maybe not
increase it that much or maybe spend
what we spent last year you could
eliminate
the budget the money we're looking at
the non-military discretionary spending
and you still don't balance a budget
you'd still have an 800 billion dollar
deficit if you eliminated all the
spending and none of them are talking
about eliminating it they're talking
about like a one percent cut on 16 of
the budget so these people don't
recognize the severity or the
significance of the debt problem we face
I think that's what we call swamp 101
but we'll we'll hold that conversation
to uh to next time I have you on but
let's talk about the book I love the
cover the fact that you put fauci on in
a mask a guy who I've been saying should
really be hiding in a cave at this point
instead of being on all the Sunday shows
which he's still on
um
what do you think let's start just
briefly on fauci and then we'll get to
sort of the whole thing where what do
you think should happen to fauci at this
point like do you actually want him to
be prosecuted I mean I know he's not
running the NIH anymore but what do you
think should happen to him if we're ever
going to get past all the damage that
was done well you know we referred him
twice to the Department of Justice we
haven't gotten a lot of action we barely
can even get a letter back saying
they've received the referral but we
sent him for a criminal referral for
lying to Congress that is a felony and
you face up to five years in prison for
that but above and beyond that and I
think he deserves that but above and
beyond that he also deserves the
culpability basically for funding the
research that became the pandemic and
this is a big deal this is no small
mistake that he made it may be one of
the worst mistakes made in modern
history or in recorded history to fund a
totalitarian government it created a
virus that leapt into
humanity and spread like wildfire and
killed millions of people all because Dr
fauci's opinion is that even if a
pandemic were to occur gain a function
this juicing up a viruses research is
worth it and frankly I think the
millions of Americans who died if you
ask their families was it worth it the
knowledge from gain of function research
was at work I think you'd find that most
American families and frankly worldwide
would be upset you know that this was
actually came from government-funded
projects at the best of Anthony vouching
are you ever sympathetic to the
arguments that if we don't do these
things gain of function as potentially
dangerous as it might be and sort of
Leaping these viruses into new territory
that if we don't do it well the Chinese
are still going to do it other bad
countries are still going to do it and
will still end up here but we'll just
sort of be behind the eight ball when it
comes to dealing with them does that
Vibe with you at all there's a real
scientific debate over whether there's
any value to these experiments think
about the experiments we're talking
about so Ebola has a 50 mortality it
comes out of Africa most time it spread
through bodily fluids like AIDS so it's
not contagious through the air and
that's fortunate it's not as contagious
as it could be
would it be worthwhile to do an
experiment to see if we could make Ebola
aerosolized if we could allow uh or AIDS
or some kind of disease would it be
worth it to try to create a disease and
make it aerosolized well is there some
kind of knowledge you could get for that
maybe he could also escape and infect
the whole world so I mean no it's a
death it's a death wish and there are
many many many career scientists even
the virologists who worked with fauci
on the papers to justify what happened
many of them in private have said they
don't see the these the importance or
the benefit of gain a function and then
some people say it's not worth it at all
and so but it takes a refined to look at
what the definition is because the other
side will say oh you don't want to allow
bacteria to create insulin you know
where we make a bacteria so it can
produce insulin that's not that's not
true at all well we don't want is to
Monkey around with things that can be
aerosolized and we don't want to
genetically create them to be more
transmissible or more lethal
so the title deception I think also was
was the right word because so many
people were deceived by these people and
continue to be deceived I keep saying
you know when they when they come back
with the next thing whether it's the
next covid or it's climate lockdowns or
whatever we're going to be really
disappointed with the amount of people
who will be deceived again what would be
your message to the people when when
whatever the next thing is quote-unquote
thing to not fall for you know these
mid-level management people and the
bureaucracies and the institutions and
all that
well it's actually how I became
intrigued in this book and in the
subject period when I read the Freedom
of Information Act a judge ordered the
release of emails a fauci and these
virologists on January 31st so about 10
30 at night fauci begins exchanging
emails he exchanges them till three in
the morning you can tell by the tenor
that he's he's worried and he's
concerned not only about the origins but
the origins could Boomerang and come
back and that he could be exposed as the
one who approved the funding he also
said and to be clear you're talking
about January of 2020. of 2020 yeah at 3
A.M he sends an email to somebody who's
in charge of the committee that's
supposed to review dangerous research so
this discussion has been going on for
years before this they had actually had
a pause they had stopped all funding for
This research and then they created a
committee that was a Safety Committee it
was called the P3 Co committee what
turns out the head of that committee
fauci is emailing him at three in the
morning the first night he becomes
alarmed saying nothing to see here we
think this probably came from nature but
what wasn't explicit and I didn't learn
until I got into this book and developed
it is that the research was never
reviewed by the Safety Committee fauci
gave them an exemption and went around
and when I challenged fauci on this in
committee I said this is gain of
function he says all my experts have
said up and down 12 experts have told me
this is not gain of function but if that
happened let's see the paperwork let's
see the discussion let's see the debate
over this because we know for one thing
fauci allowed this research to happen in
communist China without any review by
the Safety Committee that alone is
malfeasance and he should be punished
for as well
what would reforming these institutions
look like you know everyone says okay
fine or everyone let's say on our side
basically says we have to reform these
things or blow them apart or whatever
the CDC NIH et cetera et cetera what
would it actually look like if you had
the power to do that well we have a
group of 33 scientists who have written
an open letter to Congress and to the
public on this and they've come up with
a series of ideas we actually go through
this in the book what would the
bipartisan type reform be that shouldn't
be controversial one they say that the
people funding This research should not
be the same people receiving the money
you need to separate the people
analyzing this with the people receiving
it so one of the big problems is is that
fauci's inner circle the guy who writes
the paper that says everybody's a kook
and a conspiracy theorist that believes
this came from a lab in China he got an
8 million dollar Grant in the middle of
all this that had to be approved by
fauci and these are all scientists who
in private emails are all saying holy
you know what this looks like it came
out of the lab it looks like it was
manipulated and this is in fauci's words
we know that we're doing gain a function
research in Wuhan
which is exactly the opposite of what he
told me in committee says we're not
funding this we are not we played the
question
and yet in private in 2020 a year before
I interviewed him he's admitting
privately that he's very worried that
this came from the lab because he knows
they're doing gain of function research
in that lab so there's never been so
much I don't think there's any bit of
cover ever been a cover-up so thoroughly
exposed and caught and delivered by
their own emails and yet not one person
from the mainstream media has reported
on this at all they still have him he
still gets million dollar prizes from
these left-wing uh foundations he's
still being paid you know he still works
for the government he still has a full
security detail we've been asking
questions he said he retired how come he
still has a detail are they going to
defend him legally if he is indicted by
the house so there are all kinds of
questions but there's been virtually no
interest from the mainstream media on
this
can you at least get his pension cut
isn't he still getting 400 Grand a year
could you at least is there somebody you
could talk to at least on that I mean
throw us a bone here we have a hard time
even finding out what his pension is
much less getting his pension cut his
security detail they've been hiding
under a rock and passing the rock around
government
HHS which is overseas NIH Health and
Human Services has hidden the grants and
the non-classified documents more than
the CIA on this we get 250 page tranches
of pages that are completely blacked out
completely redacted and they're not
classified we voted unanimously in the
Senate and the house to declassify all
of this Senate to Biden's desk unanimous
in both House and Senate and still we
get no information we are fighting them
tooth and nail I have to I have to
basically use leverage to get a Democrat
to sign any letter asking for
information they'll do one letter this
much information and then we don't get
it for three months and then we get
another letter only if we extort them by
blocking nominations or blocking their
legislation
I think I know the answer to this but I
mean does it does it blow your mind in
any way how partisan this has become the
fact that you'd think that now knowing
what we know more people on the other
side would want to help you with this
but I'm pretty sure you're getting
stonewalled at every turn yeah I'm
uh Amazed by it that no Democrat has
stepped forward that a million people
die look these are the same Democrats
who think that the plastic in your
bottles and your glasses is causing
cancer we've had 10 hearings on the
plastic in in glasses and in babies
bottles causing cancer which it probably
doesn't but we've had 10 hearings on it
we haven't had one hearing on the
origins of the virus I had one in a
subcommittee in the Democrats boycotted
it I spent two years trying to get one
subcommittee hearing and now I'm the
ranking member of an entire committee
meaning I'm in the minority and I don't
get to control the agenda we've had no
no hearings on the origins of covet
would you say that the best way for
people to inoculate themselves from
again whatever the next thing is would
be to just live in a state that's going
to offer them those protections
obviously you know I'm here in Florida
where we've done a lot to make sure that
you know next time it comes back you're
not going to be forced to be locked down
or mandated anything I think you've done
some things in Kentucky but basically
we're just going to see this red blue
divide on this and it'll just
increasingly go that way this is the
beauty of the state system or the
Federalist system where power is
supposed to be devolved to the states
and I do think that Republican Governors
did learn from this some of them did
initially participate in lockdowns and I
think they thought better of it in my
state we have a Democrat Governor and he
ruled by emergency edict and almost
every one of his edicts I think everyone
was eventually struck down by courts but
eventually our state legislature came
back in power and we've now said that
you can't have an emergency last longer
than 30 days and less approved by the
legislature we should do that in
Washington too their rules on the books
that allow a president in emergency to
shut off the internet to close all
Communications in the country it's been
there since the 30s now it doesn't say
the internet it says all Communications
but it's interpreted it's been
interpreted now as being some a
so-called internet kill switch it's just
been on the books I think we should get
rid of all of those emergencies I can't
think of any law or any emergency with
the legislature shouldn't act and if you
need something in emergency like
blankets or water after a tornado those
are the only emergency Powers we should
have we should never close restaurants
schools and everything else based on one
person's opinion or edict because it
turns out the science wasn't very good
on this
the masks
78 randomized controlled studies the
meta-analysis of all that shows the mass
didn't permit transmission the vaccine
doesn't prevent transmission may help
you if you're in a targeted group that's
at high risk for this but is of no value
really for children and interestingly
the Committees at the FDA the vaccine
committee and the CDC the vaccine
committee actually voted against giving
the third vaccine to Children it was
overruled by a political appointee in
the bid Administration all of the
scientists agreed to only give it to
people over 65 as a recommendation but
once it becomes part of this Dogma it
gets fed down and even the states that
don't want this may be forced to put it
into the school system the school system
says oh we're going with best practices
from the CDC but I can tell you there is
no good science to say that your child
should get a coveted vaccine zero if
your kids already had covid they don't
need a vaccine even if your kid hadn't
had covid they probably have anyway you
just didn't know it but kids don't need
a vaccine for a non-deadly disease and
the complications from the vaccine
aren't extremely uh common they're
fairly rare about one or two out of
fifteen thousand but do you want to take
that chance and roll the dice with your
perfectly healthy kid that survives
coveted like a cold no there's no reason
to take any chances with your children
on on a coveted vaccine I I can tell you
as a relatively new father I mean the
idea that they're recommending
six-month-olds get this stuff is it's
just it seems so profoundly insane but
let me just ask you one more because I
know you got a couple things to do over
there the business of the government
even though sometimes it's a little slow
um what what do you think the next thing
will be you know a lot of people sort of
think okay they'll just have another
covid situation before an election or it
could be climate related or they'll
scare us with this Russia Ukraine thing
I mean do you sense that there just will
just be in this time of every couple
years they will gin up something
some have come to me from the public
health sphere people who have phds in
virology and
are intimately involved with this and
they believe that there will be another
pandemic uh In Our Lifetime really
within a few years their fear is that
the next one could have a mortality
between five and fifty percent so this
one as bad as it was was 0.3 the normal
was about 0.1 that's about a million
people in the U.S 0.3 is about 3 million
uh no is 0.3 is about a million in the
U.S so 0.1's about 300 000 or so but
fifty percent now we're talking about
180 million people die 50 of the planet
dying we're talking about maybe worse
than the black plague you know Bubonic
plague we're talking about something so
devastating that it can put civilization
back thousands of years as the people
who can fix stuff and create stuff and
make things and invent things and
teachers all these people are wiped out
at 50 this could happen this is how big
a deal this is there's an MIT scientist
who is by no means you know a flat
earther he does crispr technology he's
an amazing scientist Kevin esvelt and he
wrote The Washington Post and I have no
idea what his politics are but he wrote
In The Washington Post that the next
time this happens or what could happen
from gain of function research is
basically a Gamble and a risk that
Civilization should encounter this is a
an issue as big or bigger than nuclear
war and it should be treated with the
same gravity and and
seriousness and it is bizarre to me that
the left's love of Anthony fauci has
forbidden them from even looking at the
issue
well Senator that's exactly why everyone
should check out the book we will link
to deception right down below and I
thank you for your time and as I always
say being on the short list of
politicians that I can say are actually
saying so thank you Senator Rand Paul
thanks Dave thanks for having me if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop screaming check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell